if you want to change anything if you
had all of your bills taking care of the
rest of your life you'd never have to
work again
and then he can cheat and yeah yeah
I don't know yeah so like no so he would
have rules with the cheating okay so
this is the rules would be no STDs no
outside kids no one would ever find out
about it no you would never find out
about it like you he would never put it
in your face
so you you essentially yeah yeah yeah so
this is up front you know so I love love
so for me is the emotional part like I
cannot imagine my man being with someone
else I don't I don't care you know they
say love is a Young Person's game
and when you're and when you're so women
you need you need the reason women have
to get married is because they need to
get 2.5 million to retire like people
need 2.5 million in the bank account to
retire it's very hard to do that off of
one income
so I feel like the that's the idea of
marriage and relationships love is not
love is not like a social construct like
lovers
it's like
deeper than people think so if you can
fall in love but with someone else but
because this guy is more stable whatever
you're gonna go with the more stable guy
but
yeah love is like uncontrollable like
you can't really like contain it
I've just never thought love was enough
like lovers love it isn't enough for a
marriage yeah
you have a whole generation of people
that are raised off like these these
rom-coms and Disney fairy tales that
think oh yeah
and it's going to be going to be great
we might have one problem we're gonna
run together in the street and hug and
kids like nah bro if it doesn't work
like that what you're saying is so
important people and people need to
understand like so much so much things
come to come come into it like Heritage
and like
um occupation and like upbringing as
well culture so many things come into it
like marriage is a contract at the end
of the day I mean it's not like I love
you so much
your partners
yeah and and raise a little versions of
us to basically yeah
[Music]
well said very well said yeah no I
actually I agree with you I think that's
the reason a lot of relationships fail
today
yes like how we feel and like the
exciting guy you know like that's and it
comes to an end very soon yeah because I
mean if you want to have like kids and a
family you only have so long to like
pick one exactly
so but it's interesting what do you
think people base their Partners on like
in like what makes you say that because
I think okay so this comes this is this
stems from a conversation out of a
friend about interracial dating okay and
I'm all for loving who you want dating
who you want
but my thought process came from the
fact that is people don't understand the
the things that come with it so a lot of
a lot of them end abruptly from what
I've seen close close around to me
because a lot of people get into it
based on initial attraction and like we
get along but then over a couple of
years like okay well the nuances come
into it from different different things
within their culture and then it's like
oh okay
and those small things start to add up
so yeah that's all said love is enough
you can still love that person yes
deeply mm-hmm
well and it's and it's and it's well
very important
I was going to say so
so what you're basically saying is you
can fall in love with anyone but you
can't be in a relationship with anyone
100 yeah yeah 100 right wow when you
fall in love like I think you need to be
friends you know and like start to
imagine what kind of life you would have
with that person like you know I think
status and who they are even though you
have feelings for that person you need
to know go be realistic yeah exactly
because would you see yourself with
someone who has no job has no I mean has
no career has no ambition and then you
want to you know it changes the whole
picture it changes the whole picture
like you cannot you know all over
yourself and by love but it means
thank you to my kids to our kids no so I
think we should be very careful before
we fall in love I think we should be
always first like friends and then see
if you have a future with that person is
one issue with the whole friend thing
though and I'm I've always thought all
right let's be friends first but at the
same time it's like all right so I have
to be your friend while you're out here
yeah
[Music]
sit there just like okay to wake my time
so it's a bit of a weird one
um so just make sure you're going really
close okay okay
um okay tell me if that's better in the
chat guys I know you guys are saying
everyone in black is echoing so I think
so make sure you're just going like
really close to the mic when we talk
um Okay so
tell me
um okay so we were talking about
relationships and why they fail
do you think social media is one of the
reasons relationships fail yes 100 100
you'd say it's the biggest reason
probably why
just the whole grass is greener thing
everyone's always seeing
different guys like I remember I even go
for my tick tock tick tock is demon I go
through my for you page maybe it's my
specific algorithm I don't know but it's
just dull
challenge yeah but he got put in front
of me in the first place for me to have
looked at it do you know what I mean I
don't type in hot girls no but you like
one yeah
initially put in front of me I liked it
and now it just keeps coming up Tick
tock's good for that because it knows
it's like it knows what so what you
spend more time watching or what you're
liking or what you're coming in it'll
recommend more videos like for that so
like whatever's coming up on your feed
is what you enjoy the most obviously
it's not just that but like that's there
as well that's what I'm trying to say
but it's just the Temptation element
that like you know I mean the grass is
green I think as I said at the beginning
I think it's more for girls because I
feel like guys once they finally go and
everything they just kind of settle and
they're good
[Music]
[Music]
have you guys ever cheated
no comment oh why that's honest oh yeah
that's very honest I'm not happy with
myself for doing it because it's not as
the reaction of the person when they
found out killed me right so yeah it
actually yeah how did she find out
because that sounds weird but I was I
was like I just messed up and then she
found out yeah
um well yeah yeah I think it was the
reaction
um seeing that reaction someone else is
just like
I probably shouldn't do that again it
hurt you seeing them probably you're
still thinking probably I mean no one
knows what a future holds but okay
yeah I will never yeah X Y and Z because
you do not know the person you're gonna
be in in five years let alone five
minutes so like okay how about
self-control and about no I understand
where it's coming from though you can
never say yeah so but yeah
um yeah Ching is a wild one
all right girls have you cheated I
haven't been in a relationship have you
ever cheated no never it's interesting
like guys will admit it girls won't
I've never I've never I've asked I've
asked a lot of girls on this platform if
they've ever cheated and I've asked a
lot of guys how many of them said yes
never girl
like you said like girls and guys to
find cheat in those different things
like but also someone could say oh
liking a picture is cheating whereas but
also it's like I feel like it's also
self-preservation because if they come
out and say oh yeah I've cheated a guy
might look at them differently and well
bunch of guys might look at them
differently not pursue them or as as a
guy I can be on a smart because I'm like
I'm all about self-improvement and all
that but like at the end of the day I'm
the one pursue it so you can you can say
no I believe muscles a goal is not
pursuing
man they're selective so like
she knows if I if I admit this then
that's going to reduce my selection you
know I mean so they're never really
gonna but I don't think it really
affects like how do I put it like girl
guys the same if they admit to cheating
then a girl is like well at least he's
honest
it's like well at least he admitted to
it
I'll hear that she's from the streets
Jesus like we can rationalize stuff like
I swear to God sometimes guys be telling
us that they're red flags
they'll tell you and we'll just be like
well he told us
uh he was honest don't think they can
change you black ah don't wanna 100 but
don't want any of that stuff I'm gonna
do this like oh it's fine it's fine but
yeah they'll try and change we're trying
to be fixated
we should have fixed things okay